[Music]
being paid to travel all around the
world seems to be a dream job but you
need to fit the requirements to be one
of the lucky men and women who will get
the chance to be flight attendants just
wait until you see what you'll have to
do without getting paid to be part of
the team if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
ten strange requirements to work as a
flight attendant the look you have
probably noticed that flight attendants
are some of the most good-looking men
and women in the world and there is a
reason for this your look is one of the
first things they will pay attention to
if you want to be a flight attendant
first you have to be a certain height it
changes depending on the airline that
you were working for but you usually
have to be between five foot two and six
foot two tall moreover you can be
required to have an arm reach of almost
7 feet while standing on the tip of your
toes the reason for this is that you
shouldn't be too short or too tall for
certain types of planes some airlines
can't discriminate people for their
height but this is also the reason why
some flight attendants are not able to
do certain tasks there is no specific
weight but it should be proportionate to
the height some airlines require the
flight attendants to have a BMI or body
mass index between 19 and 25 in the USA
the average woman has a BMI of 26 point
five so most of them wouldn't be able to
work on planes this is why in 2015 Air
India asked 600 air hostesses to lose
weight within six months or they would
be losing their jobs but it isn't as bad
as what they did in the 30s as these
women had to go through a rigid
examination four times a year to make
sure they still looked good the life we
expect flight attendants to be role
models and they have to be perfect even
before getting the job in the 60s air
hostesses were required to be single
widows and divorcees with no children
were considered but the airline wanted
to make sure that your job was the love
of your life only two years ago Qatar
Airways was still firing flight
attendants if they became pregnant or
got married within five years of
employment there was no place for love
in the air but there is no place for
hate either passing a background
investigation is also an important
requirement it covers everything about
you and can go back at least 10 years
your parking tickets probably won't be a
problem but if you ever decided to drive
a car while you were drunk they won't
trust you to work on a plane we agree
with this one this time
but cigarette smokers might not be happy
to hear that you have to be nicotine
free at least six months before sending
your application there will be no time
to take a break outside of the plane and
just like you should for any other job
clean up your social media if there are
any sexy selfies or pictures of you
partying too hard you might want to
delete them before your future boss sees
them a flight attendant has to be
perfect and professional all the time
even before getting the job the skills
these ladies and gentlemen don't only
have the beauty but the brains too
most airline to accept future flight
attendants who only have a high school
degree but as there are many people
competing against you you might want to
learn more about something that could be
relevant to do this job actually almost
50% of all flight attendants are also
college graduates many airlines are also
interested in someone who has some kind
of customer relations experience usually
at least two years when it comes to
strength you should be able to lift 50
pounds from the floor to your waist and
22 pounds above your head the cabin crew
from easyJet should also be able to swim
25 meters without any assistance and
tread water for at least a minute but
things become a little crazy when it
comes to training tam airlines puts
future flight attendants in a maze
filled with smoke in a totally dark
building they have to communicate with
each other in teams to find the dummy
hidden in the maze and then get him to
safety they also have to go through a
jungle survival training to see how they
can survive in nature if the plane
crashes however it is often useless to
go to a private school to be a flight
attendant the training is specific to
each airline as you will learn about
medical emergencies firefighting
evacuation water survival and much more
the personality on a plane everyone is
in a bad mood after spending hours
sitting on a seat and some people are
anxious that the plane might crash this
is why you need flight attendants with
the best personalities to deal with that
for example to work with Emirates groups
you have to fill up an online
personality questionnaire you have to be
confident positive
friendly flexible and very keen to help
others but a flight attendant from Air
Canada also said that one of the most
important things to do this job is being
a detached person you will be spending a
lot of time alone and you will always
have to adapt to new people new
environments and new regulations so you
have to be everyone's best friend only
for the time of a flight even when you
come back home you will have barely any
time to see your family hang out with
friends or go on dates as you will have
a lot of chores to do it is strange to
think that air hostesses are surrounded
by people all the time but are still
some of the loneliest persons in the
world no matter what our best advice is
to always be yourself if you pretend to
be someone else during the interview you
won't be happy in the long run when you
realize that this job isn't for you
working as a flight attendant is not
something that you do it is something
that you are the application we already
talked about looks and it starts as soon
as you send your application the first
impression matters and you need to look
like you are already ready to be applied
attendant Emirates groups described in
detail all the things that you have to
wear for your picture and your interview
and even how to do your makeup some of
the grooming guidelines requirements
include her neatly tied in a French roll
of French manicure and a skirt that
should be one inch below the knee and
close toe heels you need to start by
sending your application online and
respect a lot of the guidelines then you
will get your video interview and it is
time to shine as much as you would do in
person many candidates have the chance
to fly to the country where they will be
doing the assessment day don't forget
that the interview starts as soon as you
enter the room so you want to look your
best and be friendly to everyone it is
surprising to hear that one of the most
important things is not to stand out you
need to do exactly what they want you to
do and dress exactly as they expect you
to just like anyone else you want to
show that you will conform to every
guideline so always smile sell yourself
talk about your best qualities but make
sure that you always correspond to their
ideal flight attendant the makeup every
detail matters when you are flight
attendant and
during the makeup usually you need to
have a professional and conventional
look but some airlines are much more
specific first scars pimples and
blemishes are not acceptable if you have
some make sure that no one can notice it
when you do your makeup you should also
have no visible tattoo but this time
don't even try to hide it because they
won't accept that you cover it each
airline has different guidelines for
grooming for examples lipstick and gloss
are required for air hostesses but it is
specified that men cannot wear makeup
pens and nails should be groomed at all
times and can't exceed an eighth of an
inch beyond the fingertip you also need
to remove any visible hair nostrils or
ears mustaches cannot be longer than 1/4
of an inch below the sides of the mouth
and trendy facial hair styles are not
permitted men and women cannot dye their
hair in unnatural color hair styles like
dreadlocks topknots
cornrows and Mohawks are also not
permitted moreover flight attendants
must have a full frontal complement of
clean teeth and use breath sprays or
mints that's a lot of things to remember
if you thought that there were too many
rules at private high schools you are
not ready to become a flight attendant
the uniform so when your makeup is ready
you need to dress up and once again if
there are too many specific guidelines
airlines have high standards because
their clients have high standards they
worked hard and spent a lot of money to
choose the right uniform for their brand
and bright uniform standards this is why
you should respect them these guidelines
include not only your skirt and your
shirt but also your undergarments and
the shape of your shoe healed each
airline has different rules for example
the maximum hosiery density is 15 denier
you cannot wear more than two rings on
each hand and hoop earrings should not
be larger than one and a half inches in
diameter and half an inch wide on the
surface accessories are usually not
permitted the only exception is a watch
and you are limited to specific colors
this skirt must not be more than one
inch above or one inch below the NIEM if
you have a sweater
you can't tie it around your waist but
only around your shoulders and remember
that no matter how you move everything
must stay in place we can't believe that
someone thought about all of these
things but no matter what we think that
it is comforting to immediately
recognize a flight attendant when we see
one the perfection
do you think that flight attendants look
perfect all the time and it is not easy
to be you have to be a role model as
soon as you put on your uniform and
until you take it off which can take 14
hours makeup is really important for air
hostesses but they can never be fresh it
in the view of the customers they just
need to make them believe that they woke
up like this
while they wear the uniform flight
attendants don't have the right to cross
or fold arms slouched or put their hands
in their pocket we can barely keep
ourselves from doing it for an hour so
imagine what it would be like for a
whole flight flight attendants are the
ones who have to deal with a lot of
difficult things including angry
passengers and people that are sick by
working so hard any crew member is
exhausted it's impressive to think that
we are on the same plane but we never
see them eat sleep or go to the bathroom
that's because they need to make sure
that the fact that they are humans and
not perfect robots stays a secret for
most of them the only thing they do the
day after is sleep and no matter what
happens there is always one important
thing to remember never stop smiling and
the world will smile at you this is the
best makeup anyone can wear the salary
being a flight attendant can be a good
job with interesting benefits if you
work for the Emirates group you can make
an average of $30,000 per year meal
allowance hotel accommodation and
transport is provided by the company you
can even live for free in an apartment
with other flight attendants
unfortunately there is one thing that is
really unfair and you will simply have
to deal with that
flight attendants don't get paid until
the plane moves this means that they
spend at least an hour welcoming you in
the plane and helping you lift your bag
but they are not paid for that they just
do it because they are nice if there is
a delay they are not paid during that
time and if there is a cancellation they
are not paid at all this is something
anyone should know before accepting to
do this job moreover you can easily be
fired at the start of your career if the
economy is bad or if they hire too many
people around 70% of flight attendants
have been laid off at least once in
their career no matter if they had a lot
of experience or not little to no
stability is to be expected with this
job even if you have to make a lot of
sacrifices to become an air host
the commitment the main reason why most
people can't become flight attendants is
that they don't want to leave behind the
life that they already have many air
hostesses have to leave their country
and their family to move on to a new
continent or they don't know anyone it
might be beautiful to travel the world
but it is not always fun when you do it
on your own when you were up in the air
all the time all you can do when you
come back home is sleep and do some
chores so don't even think about seeing
anyone else than your roommates unless
you were on vacation
you can't even plan to see your family
on holiday unless you have years of
seniority this is probably why it is not
a good idea to be dating someone but no
matter what this is a great opportunity
to save money and enjoy life during the
few weeks that you are not working
traveling the world is also seeing new
cities every day and discovering new
cultures it is meeting people that you
will never see again but who can become
your friends in one flight so if you are
ready to live this unique adventure on
your own being a flight attendant might
be for you and that's it for 10 strange
requirements to work as a flight
attendant if you want to see more
stories like this don't forget to watch
10 secret flight attendants don't want
you to know thanks for watching
[Music]